soft on crime policies leaving a trail
of avoidable death and destruction in
democrat-led cities all across the
country dangerous criminals who should
be behind bars are set loose with plenty
of victims to choose from and liberal
district attorneys don't seem to care
despite there being a tragic new example
of their policies every single day
like 24 year old ucla grad student
briana kupfer who was randomly stabbed
to death while working in a furniture
store in los angeles her heartbroken
father blaming politicians for letting
criminals run rampant
this kind of tragedy just can't befall
more people it's just
so painful i'm not blaming anybody by
name
i blame
what's endemic in our society right now
is that everybody seems to be oriented
on
giving back rights
and bestowing
favor on people
that
rob others of their rights
police think brianna's killer is a
homeless man who just calmly walked out
the back door
but said they are still trying to track
him down
that is not the only example though of
lawlessness the wild wild west has
returned to california train robberies
are up 160 percent in l.a tracks are
just littered with filth and discarded
packages the railroad companies blaming
no bail policies that allow thieves to
keep coming back all right greg you were
around back when train robberies to
swept the nation
so
maybe this is nostalgia for joe biden
you know i remember when i just don't
see how this could possibly be happening
he would care if this was amtrak
you know that right because you know
because he that's where he sits and
tells everybody about corn pop you get
the feeling we're going to hell without
the hand basket you have alvin bragg
right he's the manhattan d.a he's under
fire for his pro-prime policies how did
he react when the public didn't like
what he was doing he didn't change
course he hired crisis pr he was more
concerned about the perception than he
was about human suffering that would be
like exxon valdez doing press
conferences every day without ever
cleaning up the oil spill you know this
isn't about perception it's about human
suffering meanwhile you know
that that poor father
he's he he's right
uh the response in all of these cities
is a wcyd what can you do right uh you
can't lock him up because there's so
many activists out there that say that's
a violation of rights and we have mayors
that are more terrified of activists
than they are of murderers so you so you
have them piling on all of this context
right when we do this show we always
complain about being taken out of
context in this case the context needs
to be taken out of the story because in
the last decade we've allowed the media
and activism to create a context for
crime a deranged male savage murders a
female right those are only those are
the only variables you need once you
start adding more oh it's about society
it's about inequality it's about
ineffective policing then what you do is
you create leadership paralysis nobody
can do anything it's about the right and
that's what the father said it's about
the rights of the person who murdered
his daughter well what about the rights
of his late daughter and all of these
these asian women that are getting that
are getting killed perhaps if it was
white supremacists the media would care
but they don't right now we have to
drill down on the simplest variables in
every equation deranged men on the
street women getting murder you don't
need to add any more context unless
you're willing to hang out with a
deranged male and explain to him how
it's about society and inequality good
luck with that right now we need to get
these people off the street and into
institutions one last thing institutions
if they're closed we need to open them
up haraldo gets a bad rap on this he was
focusing on the institutions that were
abusing teenagers and young people with
disease we don't know where these other
mental institutions why aren't they open
we just want these people to get help we
don't want to hurt them we want them to
stop hurting other people is that a
consideration in
los angeles or throughout these
metropolitan areas geraldo
there is no place for them to go jesse
greg's absolutely right about that when
they de-institutionalized the population
once described as mentally [ __ ]
those are kids with down syndrome or
severe autism right they
they needed to be in a in a small
facility a community-based facility you
know you hear you're talking about
schizophrenic you're talking about
bipolar you're talking about people
who've been deemed crazy who are off
their meds they have no place to go
they're vagrants you know eric adams is
right when he says of new york and other
big cities the number one job of
government is to keep people safe if you
don't give people a sense of safety and
vagrancy is one of the things in
homelessness and these aggressive
panhandlers and the people that come up
with the squeegee and the dirty rigs to
wipe your windows all those things
were crimes that were enforced from the
administration of ed koch on and
subsequent you know in in recent times
have been ignored by these uh these woke
da's on one coast or the other where
they they say that these crimes are too
insignificant if you don't go for the
kid jumping the turnstile in the subway
no one's going to use the subway because
they'll feel unsafe and then you'll have
the nut job that pushes the asian woman
onto the tracks you have to take care of
the
you know the small stuff civic
well-being you know we have to keep
people not only safe but with a sense of
being safe we need a cop on every subway
station a cop on every train those
tracks those railroad tracks the union
pacific
didn't they used to be railroad police
where is the company's responsibility
why aren't they patrolling these
container cars also it just seems to me
that law enforcement generally has been
put on the back burner because of the
the handful of cases of police abuse the
the law enforcement got a bad rap and
now they've overreacted and they're
letting they're letting these punks do
whatever they want to and in the case of
that poor father what a kick in the guts
that is his daughter is stabbed she's in
graduate school working hard she's going
to contribute to society and some punk
some bum some piece of crap
comes over and randomly stabs her to
death and then walks out i mean
this is this is untenable there's this
small wonder that there is
dissatisfaction with government
kennedy you know the scene out there in
la you see i'm sure in the media market
and because it's national this beautiful
young woman's face is everywhere her
life is right in front of her whole life
yeah
is there any feeling among the leaders
in los angeles that
we have to do something now at this
point do they feel anything or do they
just contextualize it like greg said
it's interesting because some of them do
alex villanueva who's actually the
elected la county sheriff he's been
working tirelessly with his department
to clean up these homeless encampments
so is kevin de leon who is an l.a city
council member and it's like
whack-a-mole you know you try you clear
things out but the aclu uh
they've taken the wrong side here you
know there's a way of defending freedom
there's a way of pushing back against
government but what they're allowing
these politicians to do is completely
skirt responsibility brianna is where
i'm from where i raise my girls in
pacific palisades you know she went to
beach camp down the street
she was raised to do exactly what she
was supposed to do her parents moved to
a safe part of the city
she she went to college she was getting
you know her her master's in
architecture she was working at a
high-end furniture store learning more
about her craft she was doing what she
was supposed to do so is crystal
bayonets she's a 19 year old kid working
a burger king she was doing the right
thing same with michelle alyssa go you
know here's a woman who's working hard
their parents are proud their parents
raised them right
and now you know it's like they're
victims they're gone they don't have a
future they're not going to have kids
and that's a travesty that we cannot
accept so whatever these politicians are
doing they are doing it wrong so i hope
todd caught for uh continues to speak
out continues to be the voice for his
daughter and other victims who are
forgotten
emily do the lawyers own any of this you
cannot touch a hair on a deranged
violent homeless man's head but he can
go around pretty much doing whatever the
hell he wants
in a society
did the owners have to own up to what
they did here look don't blame the bar
jesse but let me tell you who to blame
so kennedy was mentioning the sheriff
there in los angeles that's the same
sheriff that the prosecutor there gascon
called a pig geraldo said where's the
government there with the train
robberies up 356 percent where's the
federal government interstate commerce
and international commerce because 40 of
our shipped goods go along that trail
route there in southern california
that's doj jurisdiction so the question
needs to be posed to our president when
they're allocating billions of dollars
of your tax dollars to things on the
street five billion for mental health
well why don't we see where our tax
dollars should go because all of those
families have zero child left all of
those families will mourn for
generations where their tax dollars
apparently went up in smoke and couldn't
even provide for the safety while
jurisdictions were fighting over things
and let me explain another policy aspect
that leads to this people talk about
criminal justice reform people pin it on
on bail laws and the like when you
reclassify crimes that is the heart of
this matter we all know the recidivist
issue right two-thirds of violent felons
they are arrested within five years of
their original offense that was before
kovit now that stats even higher so the
notion that people who
rob and battery and and stalk and engage
in domestic violence and the like that
the fact that they go free those are the
recidivists that's why when we hear
about these murderers people pushing
people off subway platforms we say who's
surprised that guy was arrested 16 times
for battery and for stalking and the
like but now stalking's not a felony now
battery's not a felony offense that's
where the problem lies that's who we
need to blame those politicians and
those government elected officials i'm
sure when they
caller the homeless guy that slashed
this young girl he's gonna have a rap
shoot a mile long i guarantee it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else